what's up fool welcome to the what's up
fool podcast yeah we all agree what
Torres right here we got a panini over
here guest changes so dia who rather a
Netflix show coming out and yeah every
21st next week next week show coming out
yeah man I'm an episode 2 I found out by
Eric Rivera know what's his name the
Squealer yeah yeah do you see all the
episodes stop asking me that question
what went down you're in some later to
know you know I used to work there bro
that's my first real job my first job
yeah blockbuster which what though which
one the one in Granada Hills by Granada
Hills High School I was a decent one it
was a decent one there I'm sure there's
some better ones but it was good pop it
on a Friday oh yeah yeah hard if I'm
Mexican was there a remember you see we
used to have like these free cards used
to give to people like free movie
rentals oh really
see a girl you like it
I used to hate to [ __ ] your rent a DVD
player sometime oh yeah I'm the road
roy each to read those out to you know
funny dude I forgot about that ease and
games yeah I used to like to lease to be
a video store I used to go to the one
app or a blockbuster but it was like
they had all the [ __ ] independent
movies and they'll have like a list like
like a Martin Richter
it'll be like marches list inhibit its
favorite oh its top 10 yeah if you'd
like before Facebook any people be
hating [ __ ] it live suck no flavor can I
rent a TV I'll let you wait there
blockbuster for like a year and then I
kind of got I kind of quit forcefully
quit kind of yeah they recommend like
did I give your recommendation list they
had recommended that I leave because
because I was I was like I had Macon had
like three jobs I was working school and
then working in security and then you
spread yourself too thin
yeah I just I started missing days I'll
tell you what give another cashew
hickeys blow that was the one that was
like a write-up for a blockbuster with
the movie theater with love with them
which that man right we did the movie
theaters there and there's a wiki and
some guy I try to touch me
and then dude yeah I was a crazy move
you got molested to now know everybody
told you yeah
you know Ernesto yeah yeah that's movie
theater like the the general manager was
[ __ ] shady remember I told you like he
will go inside the movie theaters
collect all the Cubs that were in the
trash and then wash them and then resell
them dude baby he's sort of the swine
flu virus yeah mm a member gihan Zeke
what kind of scans bro they wrote a blog
post about their scams if you wanted to
rob the place that employee like during
their shifts we had like some in the
back where yeah we do with a little big
box in the back where you'd get to watch
them before they came out and [ __ ] yeah
did you steal food or stuff like that I
think I stole they're out of business
they can't be right now so like we had
an inventory right so there was one time
that I stole watch blood Oh buck was
gonna [ __ ] there was a couple movies I
took a Top Gun have to get that one and
because seeing or some [ __ ] like that I
can't remember that cheap bad band they
had all the cheap moving my bucks yeah
yeah you were homeless you just sit
there but till you looking for mood all
day boy for real dawg you know a little
stack just go put the [ __ ] movies
back so I wouldn't have to do what the
customers the line people people may
have people get me pissed off yeah oh
people like I'm just still rewind it
[ __ ] like these are like toss their
money
toss their money at me and just on a bad
day - one time this guy was with his kid
and he was like threw his money at me
and I was I just gathered his [ __ ] and
then I went to go give him his movies
and I just threw him on the floor like
he threw it money at me and we almost
went at it oh I almost beat his ass in
front of his kid end up worse I remember
being so scared like I'll be driving
home you know whether I was with a
friend or
where I'm gonna check out to the Shawnee
because we're going they chop up my
movie we'll go to my house okay movie
man hey when you rented a movie you've
got to watch it you got returning like
pot I have a bit bras that every time
you go to Blockbuster Video you have a
late fee or your appetizer and no I'll
see you may flee we have a late fee or
$7 I do
wipeout like never see those fees you do
that they could there was ways to it's
like canceling out or whatever but it'll
be some major fees sometimes ridiculous
you could make more money they make more
money off of late fees and they did
awful movies an element of the
moneymaker man that was theirs their
scam yeah man blood in blood that was
never their breath though what in
Hollywood always gone yeah all the white
movies [ __ ] long bro ha ha how's it
that was the first time I got introduced
to UFC n and what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
in the videos yeah cuz they would be at
the very end and then I saw like this
dish I thought I was like WWE or some
[ __ ] like that and then I watch those
like oh [ __ ] it's crazy right huh it was
mail order right I'm I know I remember
those you see tap out yeah you see be
like on us channel 22 like late at night
it was called combat combat the more
time exactly no rules to the documented
UFC like Mexican back in the day before
it would like UFC bro that's like
backyard yeah and then like in this
corner we have here Sue's Castro the
knife was who likes to stop selling
tacos bro Eddie take apron get rid of
Faisal go struck Astro yeah they would
be like there's like no weight class to
remembers like a big ass guy but first
you know seems like you're like a sumo
guy fighting like a skinny guy with the
globe
battery care who there was no wait
clapper oh yeah you could be marched
inside if I Butterbean yeah it was like
it was like an action we don't give in
real life world I would see like like
I'm like I guess silver we must have
fought back there were rules and he
found a big bad dude like he's pretty
much middle it like Conor McGregor
fighting I'm Velasquez bro
yeah even though that you know became a
lot of party whoop his ass but we don't
know kind of McGregor might get might
get a nice kick and choke his ass yeah
but that's how it was bro would you guys
kind of be interested in seeing more
fights like that account every once in
awhile like toss one of those in there
like one of those wow like a wild card
fight big guy versus a little guy or
some [ __ ] like I wanna see videos that
are sanctioned with rules bro were they
going like felony fighter like they have
a like a three-bedroom home and the
three-bedroom homes are padded out bro
they just fight a logarithm and then
they could pick up like pick up objects
bro like a chair or or you know and then
like his wife could be padded out too
bro like you might go to the room she's
as you went into a [ __ ] pad patter
pan now yeah you start that dude that
the whole room is padding like a four
three bedroom apartment bro yeah you
never know bro like some you might step
on a trapdoor and then the next floor
brother you getting beat up by all the
kids pay-per-view let's do it back why
not do this man yeah buddy what do I
think about what somebody's a billion
dollars
who you thinking ahead like who could
have sponsored [ __ ] that I think slowly
but surely like like the the gladiator
type shits gonna come back I think
people people have a thing I mean I love
the Congress for that [ __ ] yeah I've got
combat sports and it's for like if once
it gets to a point to where it's like
you get desensitized and then next level
there's gonna be that yeah kick a bull's
head off there might be like no more
jobs row and you're gonna make a big I
wouldn't fight for your life we have
bum fights and then I'll shave mr tamori
mark martin Rizzo and Marty Miranda
broke and go out their breath finally
the bombs they could fight the bad
they'll clean them up all right man you
have no teeth you don't really need a
mouthpiece and man if I browbone fights
already exists crazy not bringing that
back yeah bring it back that's how we
employ the homeless bro you just came up
with a great idea that's how we employ
all those homeless they don't want to
work that you wanna don't have a don't
have a place to sleep you know what
their training yeah I like but we'll be
the age limit though you can't head off
okay 85 year old guy 20 on the way here
I think also mother the the the homeless
people who don't take the medication for
schizophrenic all their strikes begin to
themselves ignoring we should put them
like in out in a theater bro
and have people just pay to watch him to
say whatever the hell he wants and that
were a little more like a pro like a
street performer yeah sort of a homeless
guy were walking wrong crazy writing
down these ideas I think we got some
good ones we got much of Rizzo other
shiny umbral Heights I grew up a boy I
saw was born at White Memorial Hospital
in Boyle Heights but I working there
broiler warehouse what the hospital yeah
81 hottest August August 28 1980 little
good bro for 81 you think so I thought
you were 88 it's just like it's not like
this hitting me right assume you know
Riley looks pretty nice 87 yes no what
happened to you too hard in the face
cigarettes yeah yeah yeah you you were
smoking when we met yeah yeah like a
pack a day no no no a little agent kid
on social media we yeah why was I was
raised in El Sereno for like the first
10 years and 19 10 years of my life I
was real junior high school say what oh
it was a really pure high school I
really for one year I was a part of the
magnet class all right it says that was
alive elementary school inside I know
that's gonna farlan yeah that's cool the
first school I was my weed I really
never had I smoke in my neighborhood
there was a lot PCP but I don't know
what that smell was but I'm allowed to
smoke it what does PCP smelling
chemicals like chemicals like either
like a petroleum-based I remember my
cousin was like addicted to meth like
all the light bulbs were missing and
there was like a weird smell all the
light bulbs were missing around the
house like damn okay don't you burn your
fingers cuz I couldn't let you use that
little aluminum part yeah I never burn
myself
that's Tweaker central right yeah
Riverside now it looks like a very
family friendly place kids have lots to
do and stuff about I think even when I
first moved here 15 years ago there's
nothing over there how's the property of
them regard so like how much is good for
expensive gain higher how about somebody
no not as expensive but it still it's
getting expensive out there to know more
people do more communities considering
leaving Witte years prices right now
like Whittier and further east there
there at the level that Boyle Heights
was before Boyle Heights got higher you
know I mean like Boyle Heights when we
were there was like 400,000
we were thinking about buying and then
it went up like six and seven hundred
thousand for some of those houses and I
was like nah we're gonna move somewhere
else average rent is like 1500 1600 for
a one-bedroom in LA a one-bedroom house
that's kind of cheap no no they don't
apartment 1500 pretty cheap yeah let me
make it $10,000 my last apartment I
think I was paying like oh no I heard
cheap I had it cheap I had the rent
control like well you grew up in the
valley no the most part for the most
part yeah I'm pretty much from the
valley but a lot of impactful [ __ ]
happened to me in in El Sereno so I
always came out so you know you know
child abuse it was a molested all that
other [ __ ] that we know it's part of
growing up you know [ __ ] all that impact
for Betty where my friends were the ones
that stole my toys brochet will do it
I'm saying hey Willie Barcena what are
you cooking for more Sereno probably own
that city bro we go that's it
anything eighty Street used to hang out
I've got a man those those get over
there up a size huh what the gangs yeah
I was a kid back down remember I think I
trip I don't know Serena those are a lot
of like but that I know yeah a lot of
shooting happening that in the in the
daytime but at night you got all those
cars roll with no headlights dude I got
rolled up on one time finishing roaches
at 9:00 p.m. when I this was kids ice
all right thank you
one of these days to keep away I was
changing the sprinklers he got shot up
on the corner I think right there by a
laundromat or some [ __ ] that one because
I hang out with it I know for sure I'm
pretty sure if my mom didn't marry a
white guy and move to the valley I would
hope I would have been on that list
victim of circumstance bro I was already
kind of like getting interested in gangs
and [ __ ] at that age
I married a Mexican guy I moved to the
valley dang Gambier and the streets over
there yeah Garvey and Gambia disputed
well so we knew hey do I'd say there
knows Guerra because the gangs the easy
goats all my high school a metro oh you
can't say the gang names I know like you
represent them bro but those guys were
crazy because I used to go write my
movies at the video store that said
anyway it always do it was always tagged
up outside my mom's house got robbed
four times with the same [ __ ]
your dad what is boxers back was what
time he put my little Snoopy piggy bank
thing he put it on the floor a bank he
put it on the floor like it was a guard
dog I just like to [ __ ] around but
nothing worse than people that robbed
for you to try to come up and act like
if I ever see this guy again
i'ma pay him for that car man he lower
his car to this guy right there having
the projects he had loaned me his car he
was all [ __ ] oh you were like done but
he wanted more beer and then and then oh
boy where to drive and it's he goes you
going I said you want me to go you know
about throw up you I'm gonna go all
loaded
I'm going so then I said but I can never
go
only you might need 3d3 [ __ ] to
go with me so I had one for the front
and two of the food on the back and I'm
this phone a mom I said her name Rodney
Ronald and Robert they're our brothers
bro
and everything was cool were coming down
4th Street and everything was great
then I kinda got excited bro no you know
you don't I don't try that much you
don't have a car nothing I don't back
then so I see by the way waving at us
we're way back so I started doing like
driving real fast like making donuts but
it's a little car broke you can't we're
looking Cadillac so then I hit the curve
and the curve the curve like real big
like our foot big o as big as curves no
joke with you going forth or soda
brother plane like a little league game
sanim think they heard that [ __ ]
noise all the kids were at bro
cuz it's not like somebody shot at there
were some page flipping over [ __ ] no bro
we [ __ ] went straight to the [ __ ]
Katie windshield hit our faces and we
had a big my head hit the steering wheel
I had left us through market for you
know hos oh [ __ ] and everybody rad but I
was too [ __ ] dizzy the road brother
nowhere to go what happened oh yeah
there was a lady laundry all wet elcome
I had a big-ass bow broke man like kill
yourself like ramble I can [ __ ] it right
now
that's so that's your brain damage story
now Serena
yeah so everybody was like a run a car
and the police was there and I couldn't
turn around it to go bad with a [ __ ]
going so I had to pretend that I was
part of the crowd now people I'm like
leading our people brulee a pat morita
see what happened brother see [ __ ] steer
wheel on the forehead when I saw that
guy gay Batman you're right yeah man you
whatever to the car so they're men and
it taught them the keys oh yeah Bevers
you like it bad I gotta get it where the
best tacos in Boyle Heights last today
ever oh good yesterday I was around for
those Boyle Heights yeah that's some
bomb-ass tacos over there mariachi Plaza
oh yeah the new non-vegans that guy yeah
what's right that's up over there oh
yeah okay they had some bomb tacos right
there but you're a vegan
yes right I have you heard this company
called a total of everything
no they're from from the neighborhood
from Boyle Heights it's a female
bom-bom-bom there's also another one of
Mama's not mama's tamales but another
one mama is something in that's in Boyle
Heights or East LA and it's a woman boy
heights mama females time but to find
out that it's like a pop-up yeah she's
vegan organizing all her mom's here mom
or some [ __ ] like that to part like
right there I'm Boyle Heights to like
not even like two blocks down east
allenbys then to the Holloman gym right
there they had the best [ __ ] bean and
cheese burrito allenbys have you been oh
I have it right oh honey baby don't try
any burrito when the show airs when it
airs wait two weeks and just go and sit
down and let people you buy your food ro
that sounds like a great idea just go
out there allenbys bro and go upstairs
broke in [ __ ] gym ten dollars and go
[ __ ] trim trained with the boxer for
a while and heat up a burrito yeah it
sounds like a plan oh they could a bro
also meant you can also bring the
[ __ ] um what's the name the director
of the show to that fool like deep fried
food I could tell deep fry bro I had a
[ __ ] up Boyle Heights date one time
[Laughter]
not so stomping grounds the humping
grounds
that's what Kyle Beck was cool brother
Joe seashell haha I've had sex in the
hope I've had sex on the beach that's
for real I'm a big guy with the hats
that in my ass so uncomfortable driving
back home for an hour yeah I passed out
man no and he had a be her most of them
yeah
and the Lamanite divers oh yeah that
orange thing hit me with a buoy and she
grabbed it my job so we do want to be an
actor he saw bloody blurred out like
everybody else not even bright be doing
this [ __ ] man I just I was actually I
went I went to school for physical
therapy and then I realized that that
[ __ ] was blessing my dad works aerospace
right and he was like getting laid off
here and there all times
I wanna he worked for Lockheed and so it
was a very me time at the year this kid
grew up 81 don't who the days that
[ __ ] there's some good ass jobs bro in
locking McDonnell Douglas and my mom
worked for in the valley blower photos a
lot of the valley bro a lot of Latino a
lot of like you know middle a lot of
white people that black people buy homes
in the back row they were [ __ ] I take
care of their grass dad's job real bad
like we had family who lived there
remember all of my desk compadres live
dairy so I went so awesome bro so we
went so my dad my dad is inconsistent
job I mean he put done aerospace for a
long time it's a ballad song getting
laid off and I was like [ __ ] when I get
a job I just want to make sure that jobs
consistent I think it's funny that I got
into acting right but anyway so I'm like
I chose physical therapy because a lot
of people get hurt and people get old I
have a [ __ ] job
it paid well so that's a good idea
realized that she's boring and I can't
do this [ __ ] I'm not gonna be happy
because oh [ __ ] I never thought about
being happy so then I went and I tried
join the LAPD but when they did my
background check they brought me in and
said mr. Soria you're still on probation
you cannot go any further and I said
well I wasn't be in the system might as
well be on the right side right wrote an
appeal letter sent it in they said no
went to my college counselor she's like
look I was like you know they try let me
try psychology sounds like interesting
and then you need some extra units
painting drawing or theater I said well
painting sounds boring
drawing I can't do to save my life [ __ ]
it I'll do the theater classic maybe
I'll be fun set up front the first
classes into what acting was all about
creating characters and telling stories
and I got oh [ __ ] I could make a living
I've always loved stories my grandma
used to tell me stories as a kid all the
time nice to love it I said I'm an actor
and I walked out like I just I go if I
put forth the same work I think that I
did sports athleticism towards this [ __ ]
I figure the rest out and I've been
fortunate enough to make it then it
worked out what did you start acting I
got my 2004-2005 the first row my first
like official likes aggro it was a
Levi's commercial in 2004 it was it was
Shakespeare was Midsummer Night's Dream
- Jean or not - Jean exactly it's funny
that it is this comedy called
Hamlet - it's a movie and I was like
Shakespeare I mean it was there was
Shakespearean it was a comedy it wasn't
about Shakespeare at all
but just I thought that was funny
because when I was in the class that
class I took I was like all I wanna do
Shakespeare
I know [ __ ] about Shakespeare I just
want to do it because apparently I was
supposed to be there you know the
hardest [ __ ] to do or whatever so that
was funny that I did a comedy it was
quiet and I played Hamlet and in our
little play thing
Hamlet dog you some ham liberal do you
have any help what were you doing before
hint to fight what was like your biggest
role until gente fide I did a series
called the oath for Sony crackle where I
played a dirty cop which was really fun
I like I like physical [ __ ]
so get like shooting guns and running
around Rico in Puerto Rico Oh issues two
seasons in Puerto Rico enjoying the
island hit by the Hurricanes and all
that I left right but no I was there for
her mine
Irma really didn't hit but Maria they
got us out of that before it was crazy I
threw my eggs my parents and now just
you know to come hang on the island bad
time do they get to experience a little
bit of that mess Wow it was an adventure
alright that Puerto Rico has like an
area where you can't go because it's
really bad or like you'll get caught now
- Rico I loved it over there I love you
so much
Rico I was looking for property you know
they should put up a shack I'll be good
set up bro how was the casting process
for what how'd it tell us how to fight I
was actually I was actually in Costa
Rica on a vacation and they sent me like
my first real like my real real all over
yeah even a slob you know Hawaii yes
good way to put it exactly yeah very
beautiful I was diving I went to this
music festival the highest [ __ ] it was
amazing how much I do stuff that that
really taught me later no we can do it
today
w-wait Oh that big as we scrape the
bottom but I was I was there just having
a good time and my first time I like not
even doing no auditions or nothing and
then they sent me that script and I read
it I was like [ __ ] this is good I go
I'll make sure they're really interested
in me by the time they figured all that
out I was headed on my way back I
literally landed I landed dropped my
[ __ ] off at my place and went over to
the audition and did my thing and then
they'd have me go back a few other times
and but that was it that's got the gig
you knew everybody's good yeah born and
raised well whatever is here but Mexican
yeah you hear that you hear that cuz
there are some there are some you know
people find anything to not like about
anything right yeah so though the
picture of the other cast members are
you guys and then everybody was doing
like positive stuff finally finally and
there's some people all Boyle Heights it
better be done right Oh everybody's
scrutinizing yeah but everywhere like
somebody you know who know Steve and
I've never heard I've heard this
complaint before was was somebody that
um this person I was working with didn't
wanna hire nobody from we'll get to that
by now he said was so lonely career beer
looking [ __ ] man he was not one
Mexican man Phillippe with a real
Mexican and had to tell them first it
brought everybody here Mexican we all
look different bro yeah now homie what
do you want George Lopez bro he wants to
get it look like this but Greg where am
I
that is from Durango m-my dad too bro
yeah
the scorpion that's the dope that's a
dope a symbol of art I got I got I got a
hat made with it put on a shirt and
great this is no however I've put it on
low I'm Matt we have a Moochie list
that's a dangerous place
we have a Meucci list that's where we're
known for would she live what is ahead
Murray scores and cheese seafood and
stuff right well you chill bro is
there's our sweet it looks like a
chickpea like a like a pea but it's not
made out of made out of gooey
Pingping stuff and you eat it bro you
chew it it tastes like gum I don't know
man
I can describe the tension oh but nobody
started here in America why now it's
[ __ ] delicious I'm like you know like
we they silent in bags and people chew
it it tastes like juju berries or juju
we're gonna have you look at that [ __ ]
go to your next season next season with
a baguette with chili with the Rope is
sterling imagine what more cheese is one
mutually Mamu chili is a it's GU a mu CH
you know my favorite joke that you use
it and you used in you improved well in
the show the other day it was the other
day but in the show is when you're like
you have to grab the we have to grab the
side or make a left
I was I got some real [ __ ] that's a real
[ __ ] no fart bro like I felt like
fortunate to be on the show - that's
because I have it Marvin Lemus years ago
years they were testing the web see
whenever can see the web series they
were like they barely had a script it
was a website
yeah webseries first and we met in Boyle
Heights and we wanted you to play I
think the cook brother the coos brother
the brother who is a cook selling in
Highland Park is boys okay no I mean he
want to play my room oh Carlos yeah yeah
but it wasn't it developed the way it is
now it's different because at first they
were in the webseries they were never
cousin yeah yeah they create that for
the show then I was um I was traveling a
lot you were busy and I think you met
with them and they just couldn't make it
work with the shoot dates they had and
then when I'm when I was shooting a
superstore but America Ferrera I told
her that I was on that show the web
series I auditioned for that show but I
couldn't do it
oh that's cool but then when I showed up
for the other one right the new series
aren't defined and have to fight our
favourite 21st yes
next Friday you ever do another [ __ ]
promotion huh yeah they've been pushing
it harder I believe it's gonna do great
it's a great this started off with a
great script if stories there I have
seen it all it's all great I live I
wrote 10 10 episodes and they just like
about Parthians I think are they gonna
be up for binging altogether or yeah you
could you could knock them out they're
only half-hour episodes people will be
done with that for a minute that's what
I think they're gonna renew it fast
we need the policeman spin-off for real
no we're not when I found out Felipe
already see that I saw that people you
were smoking hi
that's a good OC right there yeah I
could have been in a bag like get a
little Roach put up the road why does it
have more scenes together I know you're
looking we got our star it'll be funny
if that fool left that roaster that wee
little when they run would have picked
it up a little later myself with your
improv and just a little bit like you
become some funny-ass [ __ ] when I when I
know you're gonna be a part of the
project [ __ ] yeah I'm happy bro and and
the way we are a combination our
chemistry is good I mean do you just do
your thing man and I just tried I just
flow with it and don't call him acting
closer so don't [ __ ] around man we look
stupid again and in college I say my
college I want to use a college that's
why we're a college UCLA no he said I
call it the tattoo your your classes at
University like Kali is known for all
you learn there's how to make flyers for
clubs yeah I got my a a from there now
from colors of the canyons over in
Valencia over there dude really
yeah I thought when I took a rehab right
there sorry bye there and then see where
that's a clean little school man yeah I
was on Isis I didn't know that's go
opened up in 1980 something or something
I remember when I opened up but I
wouldn't go there bad it's alive but
let's yeah yeah by 6y5 on there right
next yeah there's a good little school I
got my little a a degree in that's how I
thought that's how I found acting ah so
it wasn't a waste of time cuz I got that
done yeah yeah my little paper and I was
like all right cool
am I so are you able yet to have acting
as your only thing
yeah yeah yeah but I've been just a key
for the past eight ten years that's good
yeah chipping away make him you know
making my money and uh yeah very
fortunate very very grateful very
fortunate
that's not my sentence hit the fighter
he can really change up his look and
look [ __ ] totally different yeah
filly Brown with that one yeah yeah
that's before Jean the Virgin huh that
was before the I did in the movie I
didn't called the purge which was really
fun yeah I was in the third one the
third one yeah we're the election year
that was fun but if it doesn't we'll put
the purse I see skateboard what the
black guy that they used his face for
the purge movies oh yeah and you say
they never paid them for him to use them
for the advertisements yeah dude it's
crazy part of the commercial you see
yeah I ripped so bro they put my fizzy
that Jimmy chase movie nothing oh you
bet one they ask their permission for
that yeah last laugh the last laugh
which is a Netflix movie and there's a
scene where I'm Chevy Chase and
what's-his-face the woman from mom and
they McDowell and McDowell but the guy
isn't that old guy in it - um now mr.
Holland's Opus guy so like they're
studying on Sanibel comedy club and this
is the advertisement for the next
comedian that's couldn't either in my my
face is right there between their faces
yeah advertises oh yeah I'm in the car
I'm in the comedy movie bro yeah shout
out to that everybody sends you a shot
oh my god I said I'm zeros here we go
from the movie you did or some project
and you open it up in there's three
stands any residual checks that was
disappointed in no no but you see the
cheering oh wow they sent all these
envelopes and they're all three cents
yeah she knows for sure I've got to the
other day man oh yeah didn't even
together they weren't even a dollar it's
some of the old one they're like comedy
time I'm not comedy time comics
unleashed very first episode is off but
sometimes it's really small a little
tiny one that's crazy
cuz he's still Eric like a couple yeah
like a couple months ago I was at the
gym ever I saw like your episode from
like 10 years ago yeah that's so funny
shout out to me much of Reza we did that
I was stripper falling routine Oh shitty
hate on your emails I know what just
people were saying uh at least put her
venmo or something like that though the
majority likes a bimini a lot of views
yeah and mine was upset about she got
hurt their face and she really hurt
herself she got you shouldn't be making
you got paid we will get the joke we're
not making fun of her finally we're
making fun of the idiots will robbery
yeah they don't get that [ __ ] [ __ ] them
I know you happy weren't even following
a pole dancers following and then like
some burlesque dancer was you gotta put
the info on me no how about this you go
donate money yeah send me an email how
much you donated not double it how about
that
I couldn't believe she set up some kind
of go [ __ ] you got it she's like all she
wanted was $25,000 she's okay like you
why are people mad about the video it's
like she got paid but she got a lot of
followers
now like there's all the batteries are
going down this fake videos of her and
people in a fund get to keep the money
that belong to what I wanted to know
what I want to know is what was going
through her head when she was shaking
her ass at the end of it like she was
committed you that was her favorite Jam
yeah she said she was stunned she didn't
know she didn't I think who doesn't move
she lands on her money that's just like
this she looks like she's out of it and
then the girl falls she doesn't move she
was I don't be looking at further no
money light that's so she probably did
that bit of that Club the first time
they filmed her following that was a
huge Club so is it too big to the pole
that come on man don't do you read look
at that pull over
I would even jump off that pole you
gotta have hope hope it wouldn't jump
out that she could've really got hurt
could have yeah so you could have her I
don't think she has a dad like Rev Wow
but she survived all wrong I can help
you with that very last line if you need
this weekend people I mean happy
Valentine's Day Lisa I won't be here
everyone attends day right now we're 40
I believe I still like California my
birthday on Sunday yeah we're gonna come
back at midnight midnight we're gonna
back to March it but I reject I know you
Hawaii again oh yeah what's up
Cheesecake Factory
[Laughter]
my favorite there men know that vegan
was that Lawrence out sandwich nor the
[ __ ] of the the one with the givers
no pizza no salad
good eats on a salad we're just get back
to you
they don't talk about certain and some
lady came up we used to have it it's a
delicious place we're solving don't have
it
yeah well it was like a personal sized
slice of pizza but it was big and I know
and I and they will give you a salad on
the side with a [ __ ] Rance that came
instead of a big ass genie lamp doing
the dates I have no idea just wait in it
oh yeah we're editing we're almost
finished editing the English well I
can't talk about it yeah we don't have
enough this weekend the first short sold
out very important rather 10 p.m. show
yeah Fresno California favorite 15
second show added be there 10 o'clock
Schaumburg Illinois what the hell
Saturday's all sold out we're gonna
probably add a second show on Sunday
watch out we're coming with Chuck Bartel
Martin Rizzo and Rodrigo Torres tapenade
tapenade Washington March 6 largest
casino he's Toppenish will bring in jail
abide boot owner we hope so
Martin Reza will be there you want to go
yeah
I sent you an email books all right
Midland Texas I'm back that the play
would do it where my teeth got knocked
out and I got the repo Mike really but
men Midland and Austin which is the next
day Davis
no no not II read this time it's Loni
love earthquake Bruce Bruce and somebody
else and then you as well I'll be going
on first people you know at night I
won't be there is for a baby you'll
probably go up around earthquake terror
shout out to Fresno I think we should do
a sketch bra but um the first time you
meet your dad and they like like you bid
your age and I'll be your dad I'll be
funny and then you yell at me we never
do anything dad what do you want to do
what a people ain't right and we just
kill me and then break I wear my [ __ ]
short like a dad and hold hands and for
the people pro like he's my podcast
shadow what so I think things are bad
you'll say they don't know and you know
if anything know your Shakespeare thing
is like just a couple years ago my my
aunt my aunt she tells me she goes I'm
eating this oh yeah yeah she was
do you have you working on anything or I
think oh yeah I just finished a movie
and this and that I think I forgot what
the movie was but things I gotta purge
or whatever and it shows all do you have
any any speaking lines and so you know
the family always kind of humbles you
yeah that sounds like I talk a little
bit so my fat my family's my this I want
to believe they're supportive they're
supportive then they see it go man you
wouldn't stop talking shut up when I
will say anything yeah that's so funny I
that so you're now in the sequels cuz
you talked a lot
I'll be like who did you upset
misunderstand me hold I didn't bring you
back my mom my mom super problem mom be
telling everybody we go if I go to the
grocery store with her she'll be like
and this is my son should give my full
resume my mom coming in from milk it's
my mama
that's a funny dude we were talking like
that last week and I've been there we
were in raleigh-durham area the suburbs
the woods
yeah woods man I love I've been I've
been above there could please call Bravo
I was been in Raleigh too but and Bravo
when they filmed end games or it was
again Hunger Games Hunger Games it's
beautiful up there man nature is
beautiful should get lost up in those
[ __ ] hell yeah hills and forests yeah
it was good man little white people to
show that Latinos from alhambra huh oh
yeah some people from like LA were there
but yeah in Raleigh they show up rob a
meth a for bringing that West Coast [ __ ]
yeah a lot in like Utah Utah Mississippi
broke Nashville Florida example want to
just hop on LA when you meet people are
familiar I see live there back in the
day and age in Russian bro the name
streets like okay whenever working in
and still more at some government place
those are gathered in very much with
hours over to his house I did a comedy
show thou fool was in New York and he
showed up in my book to my house in so
much oh yeah okay you know you remember
me and they gonna miss your eyes oh yes
Mexican guy who green eyes how could I
forget
oh yeah whatever senior I will color you
guys bro Red Dog feed me Fran gray homie
he owes better show that Riverside
coming up not right now cuz something's
going on with that place in the
management uh people who live there bro
oh yeah they're like so they rented it's
like an artist's loft it's like kind of
like common living so dudes an artist
who paints probably sleeps there a dude
has a recording studio recording plays
there using your mentor one institution
back in the day YMCA then a mental
institution then it was owned by
Scientology and then Scientology's
scariest one out of all of them
Scientology's still going man I've been
there I definitely been you did the
audit you know what I wish the auditing
I went to up his balls bro it's time I
went in there but they won't stop they
won't stop calling you they're committed
they're committed with some glasses a
little suit outside when you wake up so
JJ are we going back yeah but the stuff
that they have in their in their books
it's so basic like common sense [ __ ]
throw away the trash natural shock offer
say you like a clean to conscious
protection yeah it's really me
surprise hey joke's on you you trying to
do like regular job movies no more
[ __ ] it sounds like a great idea I'll
be hated by everybody what some fool
inauguration or a commemorative thing
for Kobe on the 24th yeah others tighten
those tickets I have no idea I know the
date is just a two for the day you know
yesterday in doubt junket and then Steve
have a big da you know how to get those
tickets the Staples Center
you're the one who heard it February
24th they're gonna have like a oh yeah
heard about that yesterday was a private
funeral cuz I know you no other way man
somebody's cupping those tickets shirt
so that when they honored him there's
some 800 bucks dogs on eBay
you know what sad - I heard a little
scammers do got a maid after he got his
and he wasn't even selling the original
ones you know even sadder brother who
decided to airbrush or decide to take
decided to the you know copy inspired me
and I'm gonna do a mirror in his arm
mural yeah and then you see Kobe failed
or nothing like what am i friends I
followed she had one [ __ ] with you a
[ __ ] up podcast in your book I'd like
to be our freedom and your freedom a
little bit off the top I can't think of
anything right now a [ __ ] everybody I'm
black and black worldstar black Twitter
black Instagram there's like a civil war
going on between African Americans who
are for Gayle King and African Americans
were against Gayle King and Oprah and
[ __ ] everybody else who made fun of our
black legends what they had and
meanwhile were there other fighting
Latinos are moving up in the world
yes while everybody turned down the
super bowl [ __ ] Shakira and Jennifer
Lopez they will do it and Gil King was
it was like gum that she was
interviewing Leslie Jones yeah Leslie
Jones Lisa Leslie close enough
Lisa Leslie I think she asked her how
about those rape accusations against a
guy who lets you use that slat board so
they went after her a girl and then I
was his name Snoop Dogg without her hard
and beach and then Oprah came on some it
wasn't the view but some show like that
and she was like yes she's receiving
death threats and all the crying for her
friend and this [ __ ] over to worldstar
or black black Instagram shade or shade
room they put up a video of Oprah
Winfrey putting down
what's the name Toni Braxton Toni
Braxton's crying she goes oh yeah and
then you try to make fun of me talking
about why you bite I heard you buy money
all crazy you buy some Gucci Gucci can
hear about her purchases yeah you're
buying good you're buying I'm Gucci and
silverware silverware
chiaki like she never heard of it
just cuz you don't want it doesn't mean
you can't afford it so she was like
whatever man
and let me telling you but while buying
jackets cuz it's cold or $2,000 picking
apart everything
Oprah ever said to a black person
they're our town they were snooping
I hope somebody one day goes over to all
my Twitter and finds our bad [ __ ] I said
are they gonna find out this guy cannot
spell has no grammar yes I'm not sure
subject of the predicate is
heard on the NWA song I thought about
that like what would they pull up on me
if they were to talk a video of you
tagging somewhere bro yeah he did a joke
like there's so many different levels of
walk 'no snow
yeah something like werewolf and a bunch
of walk people where there was a concert
it wasn't his show he was like he was
there doing some stand-up at the concert
yeah the big festival and then so he
does some fat jokes which he had done
many for many years and his people got
on the internet later like the next day
I was just shocked my friends and I felt
like we were in danger sorry the Chang
cool arrow but nobody
[Music]
Matthew Lee couldn't win bro you
couldn't yeah and trying to get offended
for nothing but then online like she had
like I don't know 25 people that we
don't come from an era like that like no
no pick up pick up the show head to
fight and go ah I don't like this point
well they're gonna be very scrutinizing
is it perfectly on brand yeah I don't
care you know I've seen on Facebook that
the fanboy high spin like these guys are
annoying as [ __ ] oh yeah bro who showed
up we're trying to get in front of the
camera well has it not for sale exactly
that's all thinking following anything
if you're chubby with skinny legs if
you're an angry person like most women
who are fat with skinny legs are angry
about everything bro I'm gonna do some
research on that
be a billboard people are with legs
super more Facebook guys saying oh yeah
you know like they're saying about like
this shows gonna do more harm to the
chameleon boy of heights there's not
people gonna come in like they're gonna
boil watch the show filmed in Boyle
Heights anymore like yeah exclusive
homie until you give them the camera
that's on them that they're gonna be on
Netflix and then I go hey nobody talk
like that over here they don't know what
so let's see then they would look down
on you for being one of the old-school
Boyle Heights people use one of those
old like old-school Connolly but
somebody might say well liberals in the
show no but no say something like yeah
but he'll relive their no more yeah yeah
the project by herself
yeah or they think you don't give back
like how you donate to homeboy and all
that stuff like they don't pay attention
all that stuff and they don't know you
you just donate money to that stripper
how about you donate [ __ ] yeah she's
doing good now do I need to start a
GoFundMe I don't know looking like the
cash it was a fan she was she wanted him
to share her GoFundMe and it was for her
husband to get a vacation a GoFundMe to
get enough money to so they could all go
on vacation see words I'm gonna make a
go [ __ ] yourself
my father here studies on I forget
hundred dollars were they lethal as for
anything are they were our dog really
need to go on a ride GoFundMe right when
they broke into your car it was a
nautical poem it's like a more like a
bit more yeah yeah but it wasn't even a
campaign no no no people no people yeah
people just yes sorry you know how they
have our goodness people have like food
runs late I also know him I believe it
oh but you're Chang has his taco truck
right and our vegan foodies eight one
eight he has a little pop-up shows yeah
that was badass we were to abandon
Pomeroy JJ Soria and this guy was a do I
want to do a pop of comedy being short
is how really he's got a little backyard
there they had a bar set up really
drinks the guy was making drinks and
then they had the whole kitchen stand
made up and they're making in his mind
walking around me [ __ ] me doing a
shoulder rub haha who got you into the
vegan I was constipated for about seven
days bro I just took a Lamaze class take
a [ __ ] yeah man it was bad he came home
and said I don't want to eat dairy or
meat or anything like thinking about
doing that carnivore exact opposite the
ketose caveman diet they gave me bad
pretty perilously what's that no paleo I
wanted the carnivore just straight for a
month yeah we did the works wonders for
me I think you started that years ago
it's a beer diet that's my [ __ ] a lot
of dialogue what would you love us with
every meal you brought me to Mitchell
others Oh Richard nice it ready but did
I pass out
shout out to Eli Renee RG Beth am Frank
Avila a foot down what OH
our particular North Carolina what uh
thank you for which were no sweatshirts
Quique Quique Alfredo Nesta Paula bet em
but I'm Tony Cortez
Frank Avila or uh Derrick CyberKnife
snipers like for cheese bunch of stuff
here recently I was on a show called
just like guest spot and all rise did
not rescuing them on one lone star yeah
a spinoff Texas very it's like just
texted 9-1-1 calls you did like
reenactment no no no no no just just
play the character actually 9-1-1 yeah
rescue 9-1-1 they did a spin-off oh
that's an actual like yeah called rescue
number one lone star all written that's
not yeah yeah Chuck Norris plays a
paramedic in that one okay Rob Lowe Rob
Lowe Oh
the original I sleep they want a whack
in the day that went away it's cool that
the wood away Gill King though did those
and then this just this journey just
having fun we're getting doing the press
for this a lot press right now I'm
officially unemployed until my next gig
yeah yeah are you guys having a viewing
party
well the screening next yeah yeah you're
gonna be leaving for Chicago
oh you're gonna be there I'll be in
Chicago yeah we tried to get him out of
press but then they I'm gonna miss every
garni birthday party April 4th oh yeah
you have a big birthday party again
that's a big birthday party this time
what day is that
April for you I mean oh you're a
Coachella I was a fun party two years I
was already like halfway sold out I
think it's like halfway and it's not
till April it's gonna be gone have you
um we went to Pomona so anywhere else
besides California Chicago for that but
this woman is that water no we're going
we're going to Miami and New York and DC
you go to Miami before right yeah it's
like a what do you eat there well
restaurant oh I read the wrong I have
brain damage that camera the name just
remember bro big brown wheel bro like
Avatar
they have one in the airport way bigger
rooster yeah oh your throat because you
have a big there's a bomb-ass register
I've been to but I can remember the name
bursitis
now rocket there you go they have a
another a regular restaurant in the city
right and then they have the little
stand inside there and they also have
like um like they look like kiosks like
in the middle like a little strip malls
at the end of the street they have a
little ones where the yes are sandwiches
bakery and coffee all day
Fleming plenty it's weird yeah plenty we
when you see you they're having a coffee
and you see all these Latino police
officers bro and it looked like a lead
on your life bro they don't like the
dirty cop from narcos they're all
official either Metropolitan Police but
they're from all over man
hardcore fools are any day by I mean
yeah married a police officer man not
one white dude they're all like man
these do look like you think it might
come to [ __ ] you up these [ __ ]
the [ __ ] you are bro you know cops of
beat the foul and you know hit you the
issue where matters where they can
matter look at a billy club breath and
[ __ ] hit to hit you in the [ __ ]
elbow broad and kilometer bro flashlight
one time bro he hit me there because I
just told him you fell what I robot
about Miami cops are like they're swole
those are like yoked Oh Madden shame
well you want to play for the Marlins
yeah linebackers and [ __ ] we have a very
hardcore and like the Latinos they're
there they're like what are what mix it
well Latinos in California now they're
aware of politics you know but every
Latino in Miami like all the Cubans who
live there the Mexican who live there
they know politics like they follow it
the way they follow it now but they're
ahead of the game for politics over
there like when they build on Miami
Stadium where the [ __ ] Marlins played
yeah guess what you could build it on
you but you can't be on a parking lot in
our neighborhood
so there's a stadium bro with no parking
lot I've seen no [ __ ] parking lot
right way about what mystery you there's
no parking lot brother you got a point
far away and get to get out of a carpool
van I shall Drive you or okay call new
park effort mi casa
like you could cross the street and
there's somebody's house probably these
[ __ ] Cuba Republicans don't [ __ ]
around let's watch it from homes they
learn all the rules of capitalism oh my
god like like that's the first hole even
and these [ __ ] holes brought nothing
it mean that the homes roll did you
regular homes yeah I just knocked down
apartments to build a stadium one of
those homes happen happens to be one of
my homeboys homes because I've been over
there and I seen the [ __ ] stadium so
I know exactly what you're talking about
he needs to be charging people for and
over there also in Tampa Florida there's
a street called um septima it's a tema
because the owner humid the been there
forever when they wanted the street to
be called septima spelled s eat Peter S
EP tima which is seventh Street and the
other one said no [ __ ] you guys it's
Isetta MA they wanted to be spelled S et
without the B so that's what they
couldn't decide so after a type of
Florida then [ __ ] Street is called
septima septima both names are you guys
all up-to-date on your speaking of
politics are you guys all up-to-date on
what you gotta vote for and everything
but in standard you have sure he was
that's like the main thing but I got 13
there's like there's a bunch of stuff on
them and at least someone she votes she
has a glasses on i researcher she reads
every proposition bro it takes a long
time I feel like on the news beat up
they can I keep us up-to-date with all
this that you have to tell me when you
don't read a proposition Lisa it's all
like gloria'd up with the world it's too
much Lauren in the world we're
especially when they get you you think
it's a good thing it's a bad the Calif
on the gas tax to repair the roads and
stuff like they thought they were voting
for the office I think I know they got
confused with the wording because nobody
would want especially when you're 18 you
go there for the first thing what
there's more stuff on the side while all
black mist alone while all this
homeowners it's really homeowners on
homeowners go homeowners pay property
tax and so they come that [ __ ] down
people who aren't homeowners often vote
on things you have to do like they're
gonna be able to vote on this prop 13
they have no clue what could happen if
they end up voting a home soon yeah but
then their their rent is going to go why
would you pay for you're gonna pay for
it and you voted against it you're an
idiot but yeah there's a lot of local
things first of all when I open water
yes they didn't read what was it what it
consisted of yeah they didn't read the
powers that you need to be taxed 35
percent and if you say no on something
like let's say marijuana law if you say
no on something at first it doesn't mean
it can't come around and be rewritten
better you know so it doesn't mean yeah
it's never gonna come back on the ballot
again you've got a this isn't that's the
way my my attorney boss used to be he
would say what he was going to vote for
and how he was voting and he'd say this
law sounds good but pay attention to
this no no no yeah but they deliberately
do that and it's like and everything
they do on propositions is to raise your
taxes all special in the same couple
just want money and they'll call it
things in California they call it fees
oh we didn't say
now it's there's a lot of men a lot of
taking on the tooth and listen this is
the number one thing people have to
remember too when when Congress people
and Senators are running you've got to
pay attention to those people because so
many people that's how these people if
they're like if they're not gonna be
doing term limits in Congress in the
Senate then we have to be careful of
voting just based on the name you
recognize cuz I know that's how the
people a boxer was that's how Barbara
Boxer and Diane has they continue to win
Nancy Pelosi not just California but if
Chicago yeah you're just gonna vote in
Kentucky if you see Mitch McConnell
maybe choose the other parts there's
somebody else this woman running for
like 40 years
and he some people need to go they just
need to go and it looka 89 year old
woman's vagina issue if they haven't
been in politics that long or in that
role that long you know what I mean
because you just need fresh ideas you
know I've been friends with this
business person for 40 years or whatever
like what are you giving them in terms
how are you voting based on the friend
of yours who owns that business or
whatever you're in politics too long and
Washington too long you're gonna be
tainted you're kind of like raid your
office you don't have your ear to the
ground you know what's like the younger
hungry I don't know what it's like to
drive over 12 hours of [ __ ] my ass
hurts guess what past the beginning of
this year you know that's all because of
uber and lyft they're changing like the
gig laws you know which you know even me
I have a personal assistant for us at
our house and it's like I have to think
is she really a contractor is she an
employee does she want to be an employee
doesn't matter if you want to be or not
you're gonna have to be in some and that
should be the
to be to have an option that's only for
uber lyft what's called contract so for
uber it's like now like you talking
about just with that because it doesn't
apply just to know because they wanted
they wanted where they get paid like 30
bucks an hour but sometimes sometimes
you do arrive that's longer and you'll
get paid more if you you know and now
you can't pay 30 bucks which is like it
defeats the purpose of their averaging
it out though right
yeah all I want is for Pelosi to tear up
another paper terrible homework reading
live loss that's a trick though they
also use to make that [ __ ] longer
implemented and then it's 20 years pass
many people forget about that there's
something's voted on then like the next
year every second is this [ __ ] law
that you're doing in his bag it's
something you voted over 1000 new laws
1000 new laws 400 sitting on Mitch
McConnell's desk right now the new laws
but every morning I would go by news
which I came up with Glendale knew all
along
haha and then the people are going there
avoiding that sexy singles in your area
sexy thing sexy 60 roads but
[ __ ] I need a stripper money
through buggin Ben Mo Kio shout out to
Ted hello Ted you say well so what could
be a little foggy weather in social
media with a handle brother at JJ s o RI
a on Instagram and JJ s o RI a 0-8 on
Facebook official hell yeah as far as a
comedian on Instagram funny Felipe and
ticked I have to account so did look
okay I take top you have to detox
he's our new one I block myself out of
my [ __ ] dog cuz that a [ __ ] big clock
to let the smaller my shits all the same
it's been the same for years passwords
and emos too much for me that Rodriguez
Union was so full thank you very much
for being a short dog-eat-dog man
podcast podcast with North America later
guys bye